make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so uh Tom kinks Batman run is
officially over
right it's officially done it's been
done for a few weeks actually and Tom
Keens running a lot of people have found
a kind of divisive I liked it right I
mean I thought it was actually a pretty
enjoyable run it was a slow burn one of
the issues that you ran into when it
came to when it came to Batman and the
whole idea with with with Catwoman and
how the how the two interactive is you
had this scenario where it was just kind
of like even for a comic book they
didn't really seem to speak the way
people would really talk one of the
things that kind of book fans are
sticklers about is staying true to a
character now for me personally I don't
really care because characters change
all the time right I mean it's just the
nature of comics one writer writes a
character one way another writer writes
a character another way and it may be
that a new way is a cool way right so I
mean it's kind of adhering to the idea
that things should never change I think
it's kind of bad I think I think it's an
inherently bad thing if that was a case
Batman would still be how it would still
have the same kind of comics he did back
in the 50s where it's nonsensical and
jokey and everything's kind of silly so
you know it's it's it's cool when
characters changing they shift but there
has to be some measure of tangibility
there well you kind of have to be able
to look at how characters talk to each
other and then say okay so like this is
how people would talk right because
usually what we end up doing is coming
back readers as we put ourselves in that
role right so like they'll read a comic
book like I'll read a comic book and
like Batman sounds like me when he talks
I am Batman you know buddy sounds like
me but that's the kind of issue that you
ran into with Tom Kings run is even for
a comic book it didn't seem real right
it was like watching an Aaron Sorkin
show right at the west wing or the
newsroom where it's just like
everybody's finishing each other's lines
and it's just like nobody talks that way
you know and it's just it's kind of an
interesting little scenario I don't win
it when it comes to this thing but what
we end up doing is jump me back to
Gotham City and the reason why is
because over the course of a little bit
of time essentially Batman had kind of
been trained back up again by Selina
Kyle now it was a really severe Kyle
training Batman to become like better it
was really more of Bruce Wayne getting
his skills back really honing his skills
right so again something akin to what we
saw in in the Dark Knight Returns this
idea of Bruce Wayne kind of building
himself back up getting back to a place
where he feels like he could be a
reasonable contributor or at least a
reasonable superhero in Gotham and then
going forward from there and so with
Bruce Wayne returning here initially
you've got like two faced and then you
got Lee mr. pig right two villains from
the for the city of Gotham and both of
them are taken out quite readily by
Batman not only that two-face realizes
right off the bat Bruce like Batman is
back right and so with that in mind you
kind of get this this interesting
exchange where you have a Hugo Strange
and you
thomas wayne talking to each other a
rooftop right and initially Hugo Strange
is like okay so like mr. pig and
two-face haven't checked in yet you know
maybe it's just them doing their thing
they you know they don't really abide by
the rules all that often they're kind of
hard to control and it's not it's not
you know uncommon for them to run late
at Thomas Wayne kind of looking out it's
just like Bruce Wayne's back like tell
Bane like like Batman is basically back
now and that's literally how this goes
you've essentially got you know Batman
and Catwoman kind of running through the
city of Gotham and taking out these
these you know taking out like like the
Mad Hatter and taking out kite man hang
out chimeras one of the funniest things
right like his kite man is just kind of
like oh do you like what one the world
is he's about and he's like he's like
you're back and Batman is like hell yeah
so I definitely dug that a little bit
right there and but it's a cool moment
here because then you actually have this
standoff that goes on between Batman and
hush but literally what's taking place
is this kind of like this fast tracking
Batman facing off against all of his
villains now if I'm a gambling man
because of the fact that Tom King's run
was cut short I think all this was
supposed to be a lot longer right he was
supposed to be almost kinda like a mini
hush sort of scenario right where you
have Batman facing off against all his
villains and each villain gets like a
like a comic under themselves right so
Batman and Catwoman versus scarecrow and
Batman and Catwoman versus the Mad
Hatter and Batman and Catwoman versus
hush and so on and so forth and it would
have been kind of cool to see but you
know as it is his his run was cut down
to issue number 85 and so it kind of
feels like a lot of these things sort of
had to be fast-tracked and and getting
up to this moment and so basically what
goes on is Batman's talking to talking
to hush and he's like well I know
exactly what thomas wayne is gonna do
he's in the Batcave he's gonna grab a
gun he's gonna go down he's gonna shoot
Damian right because Damian is a hostage
now and the warning is if I come into
Gotham City Damian's going to die right
and so it gets kind of nuts here because
the initial thought was holy cow
Damian's gonna get killed but it's kind
of cool the way this goes down because
Damian kind of starts to taunt
flashpoint out resources Thomas Wayne
and basically saying like you're not
family like you're not anybody to us and
understand when it comes to Thomas he's
not some kind of villain who's out there
ladies only guy who's just like you know
I'm gonna go start robbing banks and
doing these nonsensical things I'm gonna
go steal candy from a baby and snatch
women's purses and things like that
that's not really what he is right he
wants to be the the Batman in this
universe or at least at the time that
we're getting this this bit of a story
he is and so would that being the case
like one of the most crushing things to
hear is you're a half-measure
you're not Batman well you're you're
what Batman could be you know if he was
like incapable like if he was totally
inept but like you're not
Batman you're not Bruce Wayne by any
standard of measurement you're not as
capable as a fighter you're not as smart
you're not as strong and not as fast but
you don't have any of the resources that
he does you are by no means equivalent
to Bruce Wayne in any real form or
fashion and so you get this really
really cool segment here you got Batman
taking out all these various forces and
then you get into Thomas Wayne facing
off against the bat family they get done
in like that it's the craziest thing
right he takes them out like almost
lickety-split I mean they do kind of
beat the crap out of them a little bit
and if there's kind of discussion that
goes back and forth right this is
interesting to me there is this
discussion that goes back and forth
where they're talking about whether to
grant mercy or whether to kill him
Alfred's dead and then really like it
was Thomas Wayne in vain that killed
Alfred technically was Bane but Thomas
Wayne does kind of let it happen right
he was part and parcel to the death of
Alfred after the the kind of debate that
was going on between the bat family and
Damian was do we tell Bruce Wayne
do we just off this guy like what do we
do here initially Damian Wayne you want
to just kill him but he's like he just
killed Thomas Wayne and be done with it
but the rest of the bat family is kind
of like well let's put it to a vote
right this is not how we normally do
things let's put it to a vote and
ultimately it was an orphan who who cast
the winning vote and so as a result of
that and you know really it seemed like
like Thomas Wayne was or at least it
looked like he was gonna get done in
right I mean that kind of seemed to be
the case you know and where he basically
tells a bad family fine you guys want
mercy you guys voted for mercy then
mercy is what I will give you and he
incapacitate all of them like literally
in the span of two pages he takes out
the entirety of the bat family which is
a feat in and of itself right because
even though they they really kind of
have the half-life effect right they're
trained by Bruce Wayne but they can
never be as good as Bruce Wayne in terms
of like fighting skills they're still
quite poor digits right like the members
of the bat family are some of the best
fighters in all of DC Comics and to be
taken out by Thomas Wayne in such a way
it's kind of intriguing because it
almost seems to kind of contradict
itself
Thomas Wayne is not on the same level as
Bruce Wayne yet somehow is able to take
out the whole of the bat family I'm kind
of curious to see how that was done
right we don't really get a full on kind
of indication here but the other part of
this of what we get with Batman is he's
having this conversation with Selina
Kyle right in what he tells her is
everything that's that's essentially
gone on here has kind of all gone as
part of their plan and the reason why
was because for Bruce Wayne and when he
says it was it was all part of his plan
it's not really you know I'm not really
a Tom King using a MacGuffin like Bruce
Wayne always wins because he's always
prepared for everything that could ever
happen especially the things that he
doesn't know about you know it's not I
mean technically that's one of the big
fallacies of Batman but Tom Kean doesn't
really use it in that way the whole idea
here since the beginning of I am gone
them and the introduction of Gotham and
Gotham girl is one how did they get
their power try to see an since a
question that was never answered we
never knew how it was they got their
powers they just arrived one day and
they had powers that made them super
capable they had seemingly almost all of
Superman's powers right so flight speed
durability super-strength all that kind
of good stuff you know your standard
assortment of powers ago to individuals
when new characters are being created or
there are a lot of unanswered questions
right how did Thomas Wayne end up back
in that universe you know how did they
manage to rise with what's really going
on here and one of the things that Bruce
realizes he doesn't have the whole
picture he doesn't have it all like what
he needed was to get out he needed to
kind of move away from this puzzle so we
could look at the puzzle as a whole
instead of looking at it piece by piece
Wright's almost not being able to see
the forest for the trees and that makes
any sense and so as a result of that the
whole scenario with him facing off
against Thomas Wayne him being defeated
by Thomas Wayne all that kind of stuff
it was all going towards figuring out
what the origin of Gotham and Gotham
girls powers were that it basically came
from this super strong variant of the
venom formula that Bane uses in order to
give himself his powers the notion of
like like Damian going in and looking
like a but we're not really looking like
a buffoon but going in headstrong and
facing off against Thomas Wayne getting
himself captured Alfred dying all this
stuff seemed to go according to plan I
want you to understand is Alfred Dean
was not known by Batman right that was
not known to be the case the idea was
that Alfred I basically removed the idea
of a hostage of an intern Damian more or
less quote-unquote took his place Damian
would basically be able to allow the bat
family end so they could in turn do
their thing and essentially take that
Gotham City but that was the nature of
it all is one of the cool things about
this is a thomas wayne was in some
degree a similar to to the batman who
last not in so far as he was able to
perfectly counter every move the batman
could make but insofar as he could do
things that bruce wayne wouldn't expect
then the question has to be asked if
that was the case and batman was in
effect abandoning gotham in order to
basically figure out this great big huge
scenario no with the bat family not
being there and and so on did he really
just leave it a panin and the answer
that question is no that what he did is
he had a safeguard there he had a person
there who was designed to basically keep
an eye on Gotham and let Bruce know if
things got really really bad and what we
end up finding out and it's really one
of the most genius maneuvers by Tom King
what we end up finding out is initially
it looked like it was the Joker right it
was like okay so like the Joker's
working for Batman now and giving
everything that's gone on recently
that's entirely possible while you look
at everything that Skye Snyder's done
since like dark nights metal and all
that and it's like okay I can see the
sea The Joker working with Batman and
like
Batman whoo laughs and all that kind of
stuff but it's like what why in the
world would he do that well you know
finding out it's not the Joker
instead it's Clayface and that's genius
right because Clayface could do
hit-and-run tactics right like Clayface
could keep you could sit around and say
okay so in order to keep the villains
from like killing everybody as cops then
what we're going to do is I'm gonna
pretend to be like this random guy on
the street and I'm gonna take out these
villains there and then I'm gonna
shape-shift into somebody else and the
result is that nobody ever actually
knows who's taking these shots
it's the perfect agent of secrecy a guy
who can be anyone and so basically what
is up happening here is he says things
are going to go a certain way Thomas
Wayne is gonna do what Thomas Wayne does
but what is going to do is it's gonna
set the stage and it's going to allow us
to get directly to Bane himself and it's
going to allow us to face off against
pain and it's gonna let us bring it into
this conflict once and for all
now the the fight the funny thing about
this fight is that initially it's like
no masks right Bruce Wayne says it's me
versus you right no masks no no nothing
right it's just bare-knuckle fighting
that's really all this is right he's
like Catwoman stays out of it everybody
stays out of it it's just you and me
which really kind of seems it really
kind of indicates this was designed to
be a sort of Bane versus Batman final
fight like that was really designed to
be the the case behind all this this
great big huge final fight between the
two and for the most part it really
seemed to be the case until Bane gets
about one punch into it and then here
comes Selina Kyle's whip where jinx is
hand away and Batman's got some
batarangs on his back and he's basically
you know and Bane's response was I
thought it was just you and me and
Batman's like yeah I lie and that's and
and here's the funny thing about this
right on one hand it's cool but on the
other hand it's kind of like but what
Batman really do that though that's why
I kind of goes it could kind of go
either way right that's why I say this
is one of the reasons why Tom Kings run
was so divisive right for those
individuals who were like the hardcore
vania I'm sorry Batman needs to kind of
always be the way he's been you know
this is a hard sell but for people who
are just kind of like I mean I can go
with whatever you know as long as just
always interesting you know I mean if
you're like me and you're like just
always interesting I don't really care
then then it's easy to kind of accept
because it's like I mean a smart person
would do that an idiot would not do that
yeah so it makes it makes sense you
don't see that kind of thing go down but
nonetheless there's this whole fight
between the two this is one of the
things that I want to talk about here
right so the idea behind getting the
origin of Gotham girls powers rather the
origin of Gotham and Gotham girls powers
was really rooted or at least came to
fruition in this story when because of
the fact that
a hyper virulent strain of venom I'd
like a super potent strain of venom if
it's exposed to Bane it would overload
his system right it would be like if you
like overdosing is really what it would
be equivalent to and so that's literally
what happens I mean that's the thing
that's why I say it feels kind of rushed
right because like 13 pages in this
fights done and it's just like dad like
I mean it happens that fast I mean
literally like the actual fight like you
get let's say you get Bane via vane
swinging you're Batman
Catwoman's whip comes in so that's page
one and then you get that man punching
Bane that's that's in the new graduate
batarangs that's page two and then it's
I lied that's page three and then it's
some back-and-forth fighting that's paid
for and then basically like Bane gets
hit in the face with one of the
batarangs and it starts to overload his
system and that's page five but it's
just like wow it happens that quick and
it's just like wow this is kind of nuts
no here's the funny thing about this is
that even with him supposedly being
overdose Bane is still a hoss and still
keeps like tearing into into Batman and
even Catwoman is they what she's able to
hold her own and so far as her lunging
after after Bane and like slashing him
up to pieces but he sends her flying
into a wall and this is one of the cool
things about this right because with Tom
King it's one of things people been
wanting to see so far right aside from
the I am famous story where Bruce Wayne
and Batman and Vayne got in that huge
knock-down drag-out fight you haven't
really seen Vayne and Batman fight that
much and it's one of the things that
people want to see right when you think
of Bane you think of one a guy who's
super smart and a guy who could pummel
Batman you know it's like even the
Incredible Hulk story where the Hulk
doesn't do anything like you didn't
smash anything he spends the whole time
talking and it's like well that's kind
of dumb like I want to see this guy that
like crush Batman like I want to see him
fight Batman because in a lot of ways he
was the equal of Bruce not perfectly but
he was a pretty solid equal to one of
his most formidable enemies right and so
it's kind of crazy because when that
happens as soon as Catwoman's
incapacitated suddenly the venom
overdose starts to kick in and when it
does it starts to slow down
Bane that starts to basically bring him
back down and then in turn it leaves the
opening for Bruce and and Bruce's
response initially is I could kill you
for everything that you've done and the
way it's written it's like he wants to
more than anything he wants to kill Bane
for everything that he's done but also
remember Bruce doesn't know about Alfred
yet right so everything that Bane's done
in terms of turning the city of Gotham
upside down all that stuff all the
torment that he did with Gotham girl
using the psycho pirates Medusa mask all
that stuff you know he's like I could
kill you for all of that but I think
that making you suffer is better I think
making you live your life in the face of
your failure is better than knowing when
it came down to
your greatest scheme was not enough to
stop me and so literally he lifts up
Bain and breaks his back girlies goes to
break his back and an intern he gets
shot by Thomas Wayne and then Bain
himself gets shot by Thomas Wayne and
Thomas says we've come to the end
faites the pirate and that's the cool
thing about this is because what this
basically reveals is that none of it was
Thomas like none of it was really Bruce
it was all Thomas we'll talk about that
here in a second but what I want to do
is I want to I want to jump to this next
segment here now there's all kinds of
words on this page all that kind of
stuff I don't want you to ignore that
right I mean technically what you have
here is you have what's called the
children's poem and the children's
problem there was an interpretation by a
guy named Mitchell or something like
that where I think he argued the idea
behind the children's poem was that it
was designed to kind of show that a
father just couldn't protect his kids
from the harshness of the world other
world is harsh and it's difficult and
there's really nothing he could do to
save them or protect them at the end of
the day they would succumb to whatever
you know struggles were out there they
would kind of have to endure those in
order to become whatever it is they end
up becoming that's that's fine and
everything but I want you to just look
at the way this is drawn right because
despite all the words on the page from
being honest they're a distraction this
comic I think would have been infinitely
better had there been no poems or
anything it had just been like like the
only speech bubbles that you got the
only thing that you got is when Batman
yells Alfred when he says no and then
when he says Alfred again and that
should be it
that's all it needed to be and it would
have spoken volumes it would have been
fantastic because Bruce Wayne after
basically being shot by by Thomas and
then waking up wakes up at the table
across from where Alfred's dead body
lays and he looks over there and just
sees it Alfred's dead and he is crushed
because the first thing he does he jumps
the table runs over Alfred cradles then
only to realize that Alfred is dead he
picks his body up he takes it over to
the catch he covers it miss cow and then
loses it right like the on the wall just
says you are not Batman and he just
freaks every ounce of anger every ounce
of pain every ounce of rage just comes
to bear when he's like punching a wall
when he's overturning furniture when
he's ripping things up it's Batman at
his most visceral it's Batman at his
most real and that's what made this so
impactful is because you look through a
lot of Batman comics well you looked
like disguised Snyder's run for example
and it's like Batman main torment about
the Joker or like the court of owls or
something like that and it's a
combination of you know some detective
work and some action and Batman's
ingenuity and so on and so forth but
this right here is wrong and that's what
makes it so good is because you see the
human side of Bruce right Bruce Wayne
essentially lost the closest thing he
had to a father after the
after the passing of his own doubt right
when his dad was shot in alley it's a
kind of side track for this for a second
if any of you guys have ever experienced
a loss like that right like the loss of
a parent or the loss of somebody who was
exceedingly close to you you know what
this feels like yeah there's nothing you
can do and that helplessness turns into
rage and it turns into anger and you
would burn the world if you could right
if you could just set the world on fire
and destroy everything you would because
you're feeling that level of anger and
that level of rage and that level of
hurt and that's where Batman is right
like he said he's experiencing this pain
that he hasn't experienced since his
parents died and he's told by Selena
he's waiting on you and when he gets in
there he's standing there with
flashpoint Batman and it's kind of a
crazy thing because he basically says
let's do this right and and it's like
Batman at his most clear like like
notice this moment here right is he's
not he's not like freaking out he's not
like let's do actually like screaming
it's called it's never done there is no
progress another year another year like
like we are the same thing like like
where we do the same thing day in and
day out
I am definitively Batman you can color
what you want to but I'm definitively
Batman let's do this one more time for
Alfred he's fighting and lashing out
with all of his anger and all of his
hatred for Alfred and so what this does
is it transitions to essentially the the
secret origin more or less of Thomas
Wayne now the way this was written was
confusing as hell and it's a lot easier
if you actually go back and you read it
backwards right if you actually grab
this issue Batman issue number 284 and
you read it backwards and you kind of
get this moment where it's like okay so
you had Thomas Wayne who was basically
there with with Bruce Wayne you know he
was raising Bruce and that kind of a
thing and always wanting a better life
for him and then of course as we know
from the flashpoint universe Bruce Wayne
gets shot into in Crime Alley instead of
Thomas and Martha and so the result of
that is that Thomas Wayne of course goes
on to become Batman Martha basically
goes on she goes insane and becomes the
Joker and so in that moment Thomas
basically tracks down Joe Chill and
beats him to death with a rock and then
after that Martha Wayne as the Joker
kills Alfred because she is basically
insane from that point going forward
thomas wayne goes on a crusade to kill
villains right basically eliminate all
the villains in gotham city and then he
comes across Selina Kyle in the
flashpoint universe and Selina Kyle in
this universe basically says if you kill
me that's fine I don't care I don't have
any family left no one's gonna know that
I died just do your thing
and at that point he brings her in as
basically becoming becoming Robin I said
from that point forward Selina Kyle
serves as his Robin Catwoman is the
Robin of the flashpoint universe which I
don't think we really knew about
and the two of them are a dynamic duo
anime facing off against people like
Killer Croc taking out all these folks
it's amazing watching them like go
through and just crush seemingly
everybody but then the scenario plays
out something akin to The Killing Joke
when Catwoman goes to open a door
basically you know Martha standing there
the Joker's standing there she pulls a
gun and kills Catwoman or I choose it to
the summit and kills her and at that
point that's when that's when Thomas
Wayne really seems to lose all measure
of hope and says like it's basically
pointless right you know Martha Wayne
ends up offering herself and it's like
this is basically pointless right this
takes place after the flashpoint story
that we're familiar with and he says
like it's all pointless like there's no
point to any of this it's all useless
none of it serves any real purpose and
that's basically yet from there you
basically go into the flashpoint story
where it seemed like the flashpoint
universe was wiped away but instead it
wasn't the flashpoint universe continued
to exist on now I don't recall exactly
why it was and it continued to exist
um maybe that was covered in the button
but the reason why escapes me at the
moment but the flashpoint universe
continues on from there it actually
turns out that where we initially looked
at everything that had gone on with
regards to like Doomsday Clock and
Thomas Wayne ending up in the main DC
Universe we had largely assumed it was
dr. Manhattan or somebody like that it
wasn't instead it was the reverse-flash
eobard thawne because of the fact that
Thomas Wayne killed eobard thawne in the
flashpoint universe eobard thawne in
turn grabbed thomas wayne and brought
him to the main DC Universe right
because Thomas Waynes statement was
released his last kind of wish was I
hope my son doesn't become the same kind
of man that I did right I mean it was
one of the things that was revealed
during flash point is that when Barry
Allen revealed it's hannes Wayne that in
the main DC Universe Thomas and Martha
died and Bruce lived on the wish of
Thomas and and what he told that man
during the button you know was that I
hope you go on to become and live a
better life than what I did I hope you
don't live your life to some cause of
ridding crime or some nonsense like that
you know send yourself down this this
terrible spiral flight settle down have
kids live a life that brings you
happiness like go do that and and
because of the fact that Bruce Wayne
never did that as a moment of torment of
sorts
reverse-flash you know if i had fallen
grabbed thomas wayne and brought him
over to the main DC Universe and then
left him there now a lot of people would
ask the question you know isn't isn't
reverse-flash dead one of the things he
says here is you know I've got a button
that I'm listening you know I'm going to
find a button I'm about to catch up with
it so of course this takes place just
before the button or at least that seems
to be the case but over the course of
all this time you know since the the
events like the one shot of Batman
Superman and Wonder Woman I'm sorry uh
Lois Lane and Catwoman when they were
all like hanging out together and they
were
like an affair that kind of thing like
Thomas Wayne was watching when Bruce
Wayne went to propose to Selina Kyle on
the rooftop
Thomas Wayne was watching he's been
watching all this time he goes to he
eventually you went to Bane and said I
want to help you with this cause to
basically dismantle Batman is all been
the case that's all better than what's
going on and the reason for that is
revealed when basically this this fight
really had a kicks off between the two
of them and what Thomas says here is my
goal here was to basically make your
life miserable
my goal here was to make you so
miserable as Batman that you would quit
right the you and you just wouldn't want
to do it anymore right so like working
alongside Bane engineering all this
stuff with Dane basically going to bane
of saying hey look I know a way where
you can destroy the bat you know and all
this stuff everything this happened
since the beginning of Tom King's run up
until now was all orchestrated by
flashpoint Batman it was all
orchestrated by Thomas Wayne and the
idea was to basically destroy his son's
desire to become Batman
so that he would quit and then
ultimately settle down and basically go
live a normal life now here's the thing
about this right because this fight that
goes down between the two it's pretty
straightforward I'm in Israel is if the
comic kind of jumps back and forth
through time right it goes to like you
know goes to when the fight takes place
and after the fight takes place and
different things like that and you get
these kind of small little moments with
with Selina Kyle and with with with
Batman and and so on and so forth and
there's some good moments here and there
but the reality of this is is this
really kind of split the audience right
cuz I member we were looking up reviews
for this and I was kind of wondering I'm
wondering how people view this right I
wonder how they view this whole thing
this this whole scenario and how this
this ended and there were some people
who were just like I love the ending and
there were others who were like this
ending sucks like it doesn't answer
anything and it's just it's drew away
and it's obvious it was rushed like that
like I saw a lot of people who were
really really pissed off about it it was
it was kind of interesting for me it's
okay I guess it's an okay ending right I
mean you get these small little puff
heads that wrap up right you know for
example the character of Gotham girl if
every time she uses their powers it
takes away from her life force is there
a way to get around that well you end up
learning that what Bruce had done is he
had gone to Superman who gave him
platinum Kryptonite and basically said
here you go here's this platinum
kryptonite if you use this and
essentially you'll be able to continue
using your power just like you always
did but you won't have to worry about
your life decreasing every time you use
your abilities right that was a kind of
the caveat of her character so
essentially Gotham girl can go forward
now as as a superhero and DC can do
whatever they want with it which is
probably gonna be nothing but the fact
remains you know there's there's some
cool moments you know for example you
get a conversation between Batman and
choc - the two of them
kind of talking and you know they're
talking about the game and the
quarterback and so on and eventually
Selina Kyle joins them and oh you get
these you get these small things but the
problem with this is if it doesn't feel
impactful right it feels like it feels
like it all just kind of happened so
fast you know she's like veins defeated
in like five pages and then Thomas
Waynes taken out in an instant you know
and the whole exposition by Batman when
he's talking to Thomas Wayne is what I'm
Batman this is Who I am
I choose to live this life you know all
that kind of stuff they're like I choose
this you can't change my mind and I can
still be happy I can have Selina Kyle
and have this life at the same time and
all those different things but it kind
of seems to lose him I don't know you
know but regardless I enjoyed it but I
enjoyed Tom Kings Batman way like I kind
of dug this this whole scenario as it
went down but one of the things that
comes out of this or at least seems to
come out of it it's a little bit sketchy
here right is there's a little bit of
uncertainty here there's a point where
it looks like Bane great basically
breaks the back of Thomas Wayne Batman
you know when he's in a hospital right
when he's just kind of laying there in
the hospital and that's basically it
but it also indicates that Thomas Wayne
could just continue on right now we
don't know how much of this stuff that
Tom King has introduced or at least
written about in his comic is gonna
carry on into James tin Ian's run we
don't really know at the moment right
we're just we can't have to wait to see
what it is a Tinian wants to do oh there
are elements here that I would love to
see continue on and there are elements
here where she's like okay you know it's
kind of the crazy thing when it came to
Scott Snyder's Batman you didn't really
see a whole lot of reference to the
court of owls when Tom King took over
right so you know that's kind of the
nature of comics is that one writer
takes over sometimes they continue on
with other writers did sometimes they
wipe it all clean and start fresh you
know it really kind of depends but
regardless it was cool I enjoyed it
right I had a good time reading this but
then he said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here two
comments explained to make sure you guys
are the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
you